all right hello everyone welcome to
another awesome language design review
part of our incremental language
development series and we seem to have
some
time related topics at the beginning
all right first up
dated a property come a year
yeah so this is based on a discussion
Jose and I were having about Astro
distance
updating support for the dated argument
to take a second argument that is a year
because currently this doesn't work in
Astro distance and it does work some
other places dated works fine in Astrid
distance but it needs a fully qualified
date object
and part of the question there is
recording in progress
do we want it to only take integer
values of years such as many of the
entity functions do or do we want Its
Behavior to be a little more closely
tailored to what we would expect in
Astro where we could have a continuous
year value that's potentially this is
like a Julian year continuous value is
that correct or or aggregate Gregorian
year was specifically what we're looking
at so there's a couple of examples
showing
why that might be useful
you know currently you can do something
like plot of dated uh this is not going
to work that's not going to work to say
that
right so that's the example in entity
value which in order for make it to work
right now we need the round so if we
accepted reals because blood is going to
be feeding rails it will work
so I mean if we interpolate with rails
then it will also work but I don't know
whether we're doing that
I mean
if this thing return to Time series
and then
well I'm confused by this do we do we
imagine that we're going to okay the
astronomical case we happen to have
computation that can be done with
fractional years right yes right
foreign
and
what am I trying to say
um
it is not the case that all functions
are going to be happy with real valued
years I think and so part of the
question here is do we want functions
that can handle real valued years to
handle them and if so are we okay with
that
difference in Behavior or do we want to
say astridistance and anything else
that's going to handle dated needs to
kind of operate on the lowest common
denominator that some functions aren't
going to understand what I'm concerned
about is there are functions that could
reasonably interpolate for fraction
right yes
I mean I have to say most people aren't
going to try fractional years for I mean
I would never have thought this plot
thing would work
it's lovely that it does it works
because we aren't around
I see
so the thing is that it might not occur
to people to to to use it without the
round and then it wouldn't work
now the needy Master is bigger and um
when we were writing the
the blog you didn't like the notation
that is in the plot just before the one
about France because that's one that
one's using date object with Gregorian
gear that's horrible yeah it's it's
pretty horrible so the idea is that if
we could use a year there as a real
because in us when it continues dates it
would be nice
well okay so the compromise position
right now is
we allow it with and conceptually will
out with with fractional years
in the case where you try and feed that
into an entity property thing we just
get an error message
possibly we get an error message and it
you know and it rounds you see what I'm
saying yeah we could give a warning to
say
yeah but it's around it 2010.5 is not a
year value rounding to 2011. right
right and if in the future
to State it only take years
because dated dated takes any date
specification with the caveat that when
it was designed it intentionally has an
inconsistency with other date functions
in that just a numeric value is treated
as a year rather than as an absolute
time
right but why not convert the
I mean right you can convert a
fractional year into
write a Sixth Element Theta object can
you not why not do that rather than just
drowning
we could conceivably do that because you
could do that yeah and I mean then it
doesn't work if you ask for the
population of France on August 5th
1623 or something does that work
I'm going to try it
okay
foreign
what do you think the population was on
January 9th
huh
well I mean
it looks like it may actually be a
rounding itself or flooring depending
I'm not sure what the actual
implementation Alpha side is
if there's just an interpolation order
goes to zero for some of these right so
this seems to me kind of establishes
what we should do I mean the fractional
dates should work
and
we either round with a message
or we produce or we convert to
you know date object and then we let
that flow however it's going to flow
there is something what
sorry there is one slide issue here
which is that in natural it's convenient
if we have a continuous time rather than
different length years
so if you take for example date object
as a Gregorian gear it does not convert
exactly as first of January zero zero
zero
just a few hours shifted
so the convenient thing in Astro would
be to have this continuous
homogeneous access
but of course then it means that the
year 2023 and 2023
dot do not coincide by a few hours
is that too bad
okay
you're saying if we have a real number
there have it be the astronomical
interpretation
that's what would be more convenient for
us so fine I think it's the right thing
to do because I don't think people are
going to do that for they're only going
to do it as an El Cheapo thing and a
plot to have a fractional year in the
case of a standard entity property thing
that makes sense
so I'm not too worried about the fact
that so okay so let's walk through this
in my view the right thing to do is
leave it in fractional form and let
these functions deal with it and let
them deal with it by either giving a
message saying we got around sorry
or do the astronomical thing or maybe do
something yet different
that I see involves conversion to this
form but have it be something that is
the responsibility of the thing that's
going to use the date
I see I like that because Astro has a
decision and other functions will make
other decisions yeah right right which
is which is actually what I was
suggesting even if I hadn't suggested it
super clearly
okay fair enough okay any objections to
this approach
I think it's the most flexible being
function context dependent
fine right okay let's consider this done
okay good moving right along
all right so we have shoddy and Carlo
here also
um but one of the questions that was
posited a couple weeks ago was I have a
date object
that is ugly formatting why is that
doing that crazy thing with spacing out
the days like you're multiplying the
letters
[Music]
um
do you mean do you think that the D is
too far from the a yeah I think that
this thing looks unreadable I think the
it's m times I times n or something
it kind of looks like the normal letter
spacing
well
then maybe it doesn't have enough space
but I don't know it looks wrong
what's the input form of the thing is
that actually a quantity or is that like
it's a mixed radius yeah
okay
I claim that just tweaks of formatting
on right there
okay
interpretation we can ask design for
their input I I think it's not right
okay yeah
So currently duration has a one size
fits-all output form which is it gives a
mixed United value from I believe the
highest order is years all the way down
to seconds yes so let me put a comment
that this is absolutely crazy right yeah
so that is the original idea was
entities and and date objects should
work in duration but if they work in
duration as it currently is
that there was somebody with a timer
there for the Holy Roman Empire that's
right well like the gun like like Hong
Kong or something where you know it was
that was at least ran out well although
it does have four weeks also which I
don't know is because it if that might
be of a you know calendar problems oh
that's probably because the calendar
switch no it didn't yes it did yeah it
switched oh God
so so I think the the second proposal
which I talked briefly with Carlo and
shoddy about is to add a second argument
to duration where we can specify the
output units we want because for example
if you say how long is February
it's a month long it's also 28 or 29
days long and you might want a different
value depending on that or you might
just want a numeric value okay so there
are many cases where we generate output
in a unit that's just completely stupid
and that's another thing we should be
looking at here in other words are we
assuming
just like when we generate an algebraic
expression as output
there are many equivalent forms of that
Library expression we attempt to
generate the most useful one
so we have we have things like file size
which tries to give a reasonable unit
and we have other functions that give us
a specific unit regardless yeah that
don't Michael Myers go ahead I was gonna
say this is actually something that I
I've wanted to function like a top level
function for this for for like you know
say I have some quantity and it's it's
in seconds but it really should be in
years and I just want it to sort of
automatically turn it ideally into like
a mixed unit that that would look all
nice and and so on
and durations are particularly difficult
because there are units that have
relative length you know how long is
February it it's a month or 28 days or
29 days but once you have one of those
you can't cleanly convert to the other
ones necessarily
within data arithmetic we have fuzzy
units but once we have a unit output it
has a fixed value
in seconds
okay let me let me make a comment this
this particular thing where I get out a
million seconds okay it's extremely rare
that a million seconds is really useful
I I would like as Christopher is saying
wait wait unit converter is documented
to convert things to SI based units I
know
simplify yeah
or unit convert
I'm a conventional was what we added but
that's also kind of well
yeah that's kind of stupid it's kind of
stupid
I mean I think ideally there would do a
it would do a a mixed
well or a mixed unit but I like the
mixed units I think they're they're
clearer than a lot of these because it's
not you know you don't really know what
you know 1.3 days is
and we do have an internal utility that
is what output start Abomination so that
is a bug that can be fixed like
eliminate all of the mixed units that
you know
are equivalent to zero but we do have an
internal utility that ties to Output or
sensible next unit
okay in case that is something that we
would like to expose
okay so if I do 1.64 weeks to move from
alpha we get back very sensibly that
number of days
so if we say one million seconds
yeah the default's a mixed unit form
which by the way in this case look at
those spaces there those are Mega spaces
um
[Music]
so you know the point is not the spacing
between the letters the points is there
is enough spacing between the mixed
between the units that's right yeah I
mean yeah this what this did this is
Christopher's preferred case is the
number one is the top thing in unit
conversions and the question is how do
you get that in the language
what sounds like unit simplify maybe I
like the resource function in the no no
that doesn't count
that does something similar yeah I think
yeah well I'm asking do we have a thing
right now that does this not not in
product
okay so the the claim is we should have
yeah
the two best unit function see this is
absolutely
let me just comment this is useless okay
giving unit quantities that are rational
numbers is essentially never useful and
happens way too often well it's useful
for their internally to be represented
as a rational unit and I think it makes
sense to show it you know make it clear
that it is rational you know you could
say that for like I mean it's also true
when you're running solved you know half
the time you don't care about the
rational each one around n on it but so
it goes a bit remarkable this is way too
close and that's way too far apart
can um Avery could you please screen
capture these give these to design let's
try and get yep I've been grabbing them
I'll pass it over
okay so so there is a notation in unit
converter that Nick added uh to the chat
in in which you have to specify the the
actual
units yeah no that's not useful I mean
it's it's fine but it's it's look the
issue is we need some way and maybe it's
unit simplify maybe it's a better you
know slightly improved unit simplify
which I had forgotten existed
so now you need to simplify tries to get
the unit in which the magnitude is
closer to one which I think is a good
thing yeah it's good so we're good to
have a second argument
saying I want mixed units yeah figure
out the best mix unit it'll be
reasonable
interesting why did that not turn it
into past X
because
we had a similar discussion we decided
that parsecs were too weird for you you
for the general users
unless they get very large yeah yeah
there's a lot of heuristics that go into
it and it
tricky to get right in all cases but
yeah okay and so the only problem is
and let me just in response to your
objection to rational units I can think
of at least or magnitudes I can think of
at least one context in which that's
exactly what you want which is cooking
right you want half a cup three quarters
of a cup
right
um fair enough okay but okay so look
first point is a little bit of
Investigation if you're not simplify the
possibility of a second argument that
gives mixed units
that seems highly useful
second Point here
is so
what's the question here about duration
what was the basic idea here
so the original request that had come up
briefly in a couple of meetings was
duration should work on data objects it
should also work on entities
and the question is while we're at it it
would probably be nice to specify what
kind of units you want the duration in
and do we want to examine the default
output what does duration of date object
mean it's like the duration of the
implicit interval of the granule of the
granularity yeah so duration could be
zero yep yeah yeah it was an instant
and it already works on date interval
for explicit intervals no I tell you
what it should really return is the
elementary time
right
um
go ahead
I mean okay so this here which is not
actually a built-in thing anyway yet
just needs to be cleaned
right yeah yeah I mean we can basically
something that I can take out of I think
eliminating all of those zero days Zero
Hour things yeah I know but we shouldn't
even have mixed units 845 years four
weeks is just wrong
okay so some of these things we should
know the granularity and not generate
things beyond the granularity I'm sure
that in this case if I ask for the start
date of the Holy Roman Empire it better
be the case that it does not have unless
you know I'm supposed to start a
particular day but but um
uh what is it start date
yeah start date
really
there might have been a treaty right
yeah
probably put a crown onto somebody into
the throne right that's where the pope
Crown somebody
or something
that's about the right although actually
Wikipedia said there was on the 25th of
December 800 that maybe this is a
different
oh I don't know there's a type there was
also a no never mind there's another
thing that happened in 962 so
yeah do you think it's actually right
yeah
right right you know yeah right don't
think I'd ever heard of it then being
800 plus years
what the Holy Roman Empire hre it is it
is yes
Charlemagne is 800 until Napoleon
yeah
okay all right
and the one before this
is great yeah just remember it's neither
holy nor Roman nor much of an Empire
I have heard that yes and they didn't
and they didn't have computers with the
internet the Holy Roman Empire is none
is what the saying has been
yeah I mean so this is a case where we
do have granularity
this is just
it's the difference between how
duration is currently handling
extracting the exact values from a data
interval so it's just wrong it's just
wrong if you if you subtract two things
with a granularity of a year you should
get an answer that has a granularity of
a year not a thing that has a
granularity that has it's an instant
end date minus start date for the
Hundred Years War you get 100 years
right I mean one one thing though that's
a little subtle is just the fact that
dates we can explicitly say the
granularity is year as opposed to when
you get the quantity out when presumably
is just going to be a rounded number
you're right but at least we shouldn't
try and mix Radix it and put crazy stuff
in I mean look if it's yeah minus year
we should have an interior come out in
my view
and certainly no mixed Radix nonsense
right but there's maybe even an argument
this well there's maybe an argument that
a mixed Radix unit if it's a zero it
should just ignore that yeah that place
but but you know it might be a bit bad
in terms of just it's hiding how it's
internally represented in the way that
might cause confusion
and they can certainly think of contexts
where you actually do want to see those
zeros
fine right but I think there's minute
seconds
right I think it should honestly present
it I think this was just a bug in the
way that this lowercase duration
function works for this quantity for
this entity here
yeah
yeah so that was basically one of the
points is if we want to extend this to
work on other things do we want the
output units form to be different or do
we at the same time want to look at
extending duration to allow an explicit
second argument that says what you want
potentially I would say the second
argument is the units
unmixed would be the generic units
okay but we'll be mixed Radix
I mean
you know we might want to say you want
hours and minutes but you don't want
seconds which is a more subtle thing
but I think that's a different issue I
mean that look duration rounded to hours
seems quite reasonable
and
duration in which the thing in there is
something which only has a certain
granularity we know what to do
okay
make sense everybody
do you have any concerns on the audio
side Carlo or does that also make sense
that sounds useful for the audio side as
well
um and again the one case that we've
found a duration wanting many times is
for it to a term just a number
representing a number of seconds and
that's the duration of something common
none in this proposal that would be very
convenient I would say just ditch the
units return something as
seconds as a real number
I I think then the question is that for
other types of inputs what is the
default unit is
is there any way we can say seconds but
no unit
no that's what Carlo just said you put
none in there it'll return with no units
what I'm saying is that for audio we
think seconds would be useful for
entities seconds may not be really the
most I know so none is not the default
the default is automatic and the
automatic default would return in the
case of the you know some historical
thing it's probably granular to a year
in which case it just returns in years
in the case you mean you mean it's just
a it's just an integer or a real in
years
with units of rears yes
but you're right as a Quant I'm just
saying right if we're talking about the
case where you get it to not where you
get to return a naked number without a
quantity is that what you mean or I'm
saying that the only case that does that
is base SI based units I.E seconds okay
common none
as a second argument I think that's what
I was making sure it makes sense and and
yeah the amendment to this proposal will
be the last thing as you were saying
duration of income automatic the default
is not the mixed unit the default
depends on what the input is exactly he
said if the input is something that has
used then it will be years yep okay
nobody agree here
I think so yes okay
let us move on
nothing else for this
oh okay next item do it
so these are a handful of wfr functions
we were looking at reviewing they
happened to all be proposed by sander
who's a regular viewer of art live
streams
um
this is not so this is related to delete
duplicates but obviously has
different results
you know we're we're selecting the
elements where they're
that are duplicated within the list and
dropping All The Singletons
well I mean
how would you do what is the most
obvious thing if you want to drop if you
want to include only things that occur
more than n times
is there an easy way to do that
dude
tally or whatever and just take the ones
that have more than two yeah
right if you want to you could do delete
cases of Alternatives at
uh Delete duplicates
we're not delete duplicates but like uh
selective counts comma yeah you know
greater than one
yeah right but but right or or I mean
there are two versions of this one is
the version that Sandra has here which
is that it keeps them in order with
duplication and so on the others that
just sort of set operation which I think
is like you know complement of list
commonly duplicates of list
foreign
I think yeah right it's not
I don't I don't really see where you
would use this it does seem like
something where
you know if you wrote it yourself it
would be less efficient than if we're
built in but I'm not sure when you would
use this no that's sort of because it
isn't being compiled one day it will be
compiled I think once in a while you you
do want to know okay which ones have
multiplicity here
um that doesn't necessarily mean you
want more information well accounts
tells you which ones have what yeah yeah
yeah true I'm not I'm not seeing this I
I think this is one where
it's going to be more effort to remember
that the thing exists than it is to
rewrite it
okay
what is this this is is that is it hair
wise or is it is it going to just
compare all of them to the first one or
something like that
I believe it Compares all of them to the
first one
yeah if you don't have a transitive
comparison
yeah then there's an issue we're not
clear what it should do yeah
but but if you don't have a transitive
comparison I mean or like if you have to
do all the pairs you might be in trouble
so yeah yeah I agree with you
um I think the buy functions we kind of
make assumptions like that right like
sort by kind of assumes that the
function is deterministic for instance
true
is it not just mapping the function over
the whole list and doing like the VAR
ARG same queue
it's effectively doing that but it's
more efficient okay but that's not
ambiguous
yeah that's equivalent to comparing them
all to the first right right it's just
yeah yeah they're all the same
this seems somewhat useful yeah it's
it's along the same lines as all true
where you know I have a collection of
things and I want to make sure
right and the way you do it yourself is
same cue at at F slash at list right
yeah right imagine all the elements are
associations then you want to see if a
specific key is the same in all of them
it's really useful then I like this
function this is a good idea
do we have an all same as well
same as as a operator for
well I I just mean like well okay
sure right I mean I you might think that
there's a in this sort sort by
distinction there might be another
version that's the version that that you
give it uh like uh a comparison operator
you know it takes two arguments but that
that would probably have to do the N
squared thing and it would be really
slow yeah and I think this really same
cue at that seems like
I think this is useful
and the name seems reasonable so I'm I'm
good with this
okay excellent thank you Sandra look at
promoting that uh so Gosha is just
joining in to potentially talk about
this as well but uh
um
apropos of this
I used a similar phrase in talking to
somebody not too long ago and was told
that the term is falling out of fashion
foreign
not making that up I know I know
um
you know in the end the only language
that's going to be perfectly acceptable
is the language that has just one Grunt
in it
and then people are going to be
surprised that nobody can communicate
um
the okay
kind of just commenting contested easy
whether all the prime or all the complex
that's important but it's not that you
can write to these other shortcut yes
yes we understand
the um
okay
okay let's look at this what is this
appearance Matrix set empty Matrix what
is this doing
's Matrix
so so Wikipedia says it's a what can be
called a whitening transform or a
spherical transform
Ed pre-scaling
thing how does it relate to standardize
standardized wouldn't change the ship
only shift and rescale so the ellipse
was would still be there
this is kind of rounding this is like
eliminating the shear
return the transformation matrix as well
no
yeah
well it could give you the maybe the way
of getting the Matrix that it's using
yeah yeah that would be useful for some
purposes but this is similar in terms of
objective to standardized is that a true
statement
similar yes
that's where the name whitening comes
from
Christina try Vector around of X
evaluate the x that Santa gave
okay the sex it's the compressed data
yeah
X and try a vector around
so you see this is in the first argument
you get this the the center
and in the second covariance Matrix so
standardized will change
the the center to be 0 0 and the
covariance Matrix to be diagonals one
yep but but it will still be a full
Matrix well this is going to convert the
second argument into the identity Matrix
right
so in a sense
it might be a little bit
more I mean to call it sphericalize or
something might be
more in line with standardized and
normalize
correct
and
let's see where would you use this
oh look Spirit transformation okay
I mean
it seems like a
I mean it would seem like standardized
normalize
it seems more like sphere eyes or
something
because when we say transform usually
that is
don't we usually mean something rather
different when we say transform
yeah they usually give a transformation
function I think
um
well do they I mean is that
terrible that's not the case for like Z
transform right right the like the
or Fourier transform right those are
you know there's so many integral
transforms are just called transform
is it a simplexomorphism
the hell is that
well if first of all it's got to do a
sheer I guess but then if it shears and
it's still an oval you're trying to turn
the oval into a circle so you can ask
the question whether or not that final
transformation
preserves a interior area
okay where does one use this
we're moving right now you're trying to
find when you're trying to find
independent variables right you're
trying to decorate
right you you have some data and some
variables and you're trying to find new
variables that are independent
um
honestly it seems like this would also
be useful in like you know machine
learning things it's just you know a
similar function to what you might use
standardized for just one-dimensional
data
yes
as a way of understanding your data
better you can also if I remember
um correctly remove
um components of a signal
um to in order to uh try to analyze
other components that might not show up
as well with the main ones still there I
mean in this case this case is kind of a
bad case because actually it is white
noise in the end
whereas if this had more structure to it
this thing would show structure even in
the in the you know sort of reduced case
right
yep
can you get an example of that
maybe something with Primes
uh let's see what's up what's a good
thing that's like correlated like this
um
well I don't know difference between
primes or something and if we take take
something like um
uh
am I going to get this wrong hold on
what am I thinking about here
uh
what am I trying to do
um crime of X and log of x
what we could do yeah
except X we need to get rid of because
we're about to blow ourselves up here
hmm
this is going to be
a line more than a cloud right
it'll be close to a line
well
so maybe we want log minus
I don't know I mean but maybe yeah you
could take the successive differences
what
what happened yeah oh whoops I put that
advice
take
differences of both of those
lists Prime X and log X
can't just say differences of the whole
table
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh whatever that's not quite what I but
let's take a look at what happens if we
apply this transformation here
to that
hmm
okay
I think this is not really the right
input data for this no it's not right
probably not
okay well I I can't tell exactly it
would be nice to know from the machine
learning group what they think about
this
and you know the spherize thing would be
probably the least
incomprehensible version of this
comments from people
I mean the spare the term spherical
transform or whatever it was called I
think it sounds too much like a
transform of a sphere
right but spherize and sphering
definition spherize
would give some sense of it's going to
try and turn it into something which is
you know
okay yeah maybe maybe spherized yeah
that would be my tentative suggestion
yes it is similar to I mean it's a
flavor of I guess the geometric
transforms isn't it
I guess not because we have to account
for this point by point it's not just a
much more like standardized I think it's
a version of standardized isn't it yeah
yeah
it's a fair analogy
that's what I think I think this is a
good thing
um
a little bit more slowly I would not
consider this particularly high priority
but I think it's nice
yeah we'll take it to the ml group and
see if they have any immediate comments
okay it's going to be more as fairized
than diamond eyes I think based on the
norm in question yeah yeah
that's a special case that it diamonds
buys
your point Brad is this try running it a
couple times though
yeah maybe you should do um
you could also do um uh aspect ratio
automatic
and is aspect ratio automatic so low
down in the ranking
foreign do
anybody know here
um I somebody should fix that
autocomplete to make us Patricia to
automatically be in place of aspiration
full I don't even know what that does
anybody want to offer us idea of what
aspartation of fall does
it's definitely a brat question
inclusion region that's actually very
rare we should change that autocomplete
Avery can you take care of that
yeah
I got that
okay so the uh is there a point Brad
that that we don't like the name Sparrow
eyes because these aren't Sparkle well
no I was making a joke kind of but the
point of these plots here I think is
that it answers the question about
um preservation of internal area because
it's mapping a unit square and what we
see here is does not look like a unit
Square to me
I have no opinions about this this seems
like more of a
I mean we can we could try and recover I
don't know can we take the region here
how do we do that how do we do the
region reconstruct like convex hole or
something no no not come Excel I mean we
could do comics on this case because
there's more or less Comics so what's
the what's the new function that we
introduced that tries to approximate a
region
non-convex Hull mesh yeah but but
there's a better name we have we have a
more generic name for that now
Regency
um what reason if it was like finding
you know the bounding you know um why
does it say zero arguments it's got one
argument there
somebody fixed that please
make sense
yep we'll pass it along
I'm confused by the cell what I was
looking for was a thing which was going
to return to me you know you know I'm
talking about it I just want that well
whatever we could just say convex Hull
okay now I could say area of that
and that's it is it's concave whole mesh
as I think what you're what you're
looking for okay but in any case this is
if I say Graphics of percent 31 so I'm a
little bit confused now by what this is
I thought this was a unit okay there
they are
like does it so this is trying to bring
covariance to one it's a bit like
a normal distribution right it it's
extended but it has Sigma 1.
okay
right but so can I ask the question does
the area like let's say that you have
roughly a convex hole is an ellipsoid or
it's a square if you do this
transformation is it going to change the
area of your distribution of points
yes yes it will rescale so that the
sigma corresponding to this is one
so so some points inside some points
will be outside
what they think about it
let's move on and just have a quick look
at some of these Plantation things we
can handle some of these quickly we
should
well yeah this should be what
permutations does
on an association is to permute
the values for fixed keys right
this one is promoting the key value
pairs which I think is more useful
so B is always associated with two yeah
it's just gives you the order
oh you can make the argument that should
you know just preview the values that
kind of follows the fundamentals what it
should do
it seems less useful
well I I would argue it's more useful to
permute the values because I mean most
of the time you don't care about the
order of the association anyway right
and if you want the other case turn the
association into a list permute the list
and turn it back to an association
manipulate both the original and the
permuted Association then you need the
keys to remain in the same order
right I think let me as you say
permutation should be extended it should
permute the values that's yeah it should
do something one of those two yeah I
think that's fine yeah
so the work order there is extend
permutations to association yes okay yes
but just on the values so not like yeah
I understood yeah
select permutations
so I mean this is part of the whole
family of lazy operations
this is like the permutations generator
and this is a lazy and that's where this
should be not its own separate function
do we have a general
section of permutation related things in
lazy evaluation well we're trying to I
mean we need to move forward with laser
evaluation I haven't seen a meeting
about that recently and we should have
one
um it's not necessarily even lazy so
much as conserving of memory
if you only if you ask for just like you
know the first n of them then sure it's
lazy but if you want them all
what you're really doing is saving on
memory yeah but but you could do that as
a lazy Thing by saying here's this thing
okay it's also part of like the infinite
lists project here's this huge
collection of permutations now just give
me this one slice of it
yeah if that slice is finite
well I mean with permutations we're not
dealing with actually infinite lists of
20 elements or something
we're just saying we don't actually want
to generate that list of 20 elements we
want to lazily be able to find those
cases where there's some you know
ascending sequence of whatever yeah no
my point is simply that for practical
purposes we are generating all of them
just one at a time we're not generating
the whole subang you know and putting it
in memory
but in a perfect world we would have a
more efficient strategy for essentially
compiling the function that you are
trying to select permutations that
satisfy
so we're not is what I'm saying
yeah you could just do it by a generator
that you know internally makes the
permutation does not first make a list
of all permutations and then select from
it but just go sequentially doing the
next permutation type thing yeah no
that's what I'm saying so you're still
generating all of them but just not all
at once I know I know that what I'm
saying is there should be a way to be
smarter than that and to say we can
essentially compile the Criterion so we
don't even have to look at every single
one
we can just take hold in some in some
cases depending on what your Criterion
is you you can do that you know for
instance you want the alternating ones
or something like that
um I know but I'm saying that designs
have a function go ahead we're just I'm
just I'm just gonna say a lot of the
time I don't think you can analyze the
Criterion that much right it could use
permutations of integers and you're
doing some you know nice classic
combinatorics thing maybe you can but if
you're you know I don't know you're
looking at permutations of layers of a
neural network or something it's like
this is It's doomed
I I think that when people are in the
first situation if they're good at what
they're doing they will actually already
you know just generate the ones they
need on the Fly and not go through the
whole list listen I think this function
should be part of the story of lazy
evaluation and infinite lists and not
its own separate functions for
permutations
does anybody disagree with that idea
yeah I think I kind of agree partly
because I mean right partly just because
you you'd also want to have permutation
map and permutation scan or actually
permutation map is not that useful
permutation scan would be useful yes um
yeah yeah and we want this for subsets
and doubles and yeah right yeah
okay
I have no opinion about the arrangement
queue
seems mildly useful doesn't seem
profound seems mildly useful
I I'm I'm just not clear whether there
are cases where I mean it's it's a thing
with a very clear name
it has been requested sometimes well
then we should just have it
okay next permutation is related to next
subsets and all the other next functions
is that not also something that is part
of the lazy story
yes yep
so that's where it should go it's a very
useful functionality and we should have
it
I have no opinion about this is this
useful because I mean I know that there
are formulas in I don't know there's one
with gamma matrices I think where you
take only odd permutations of the
indices
I mean you can multiply both is this
thing any more efficient than just you
know
select permutation signature
equals one I'm guessing yes but I don't
know for sure
I mean yeah it is however
even permutations or permutations my
question is this
in like physics formulas is it the case
that you often say you know product over
even permutations for example if the
answer is yes it would be nice to have
an encapsulated function you just say
even permutations
I don't I don't think you have many
formulas like that I mean I think most
formulas are you know
whatever over permutations
with minus one to the yeah
of signature
we have the general group elements
function that can take
that can create the elements of any
group and these even permutations are
the elements for the alternating groups
so we have a way of generating them it's
just that they can as Cycles so we have
to do our final step of converting into
permutation lists
it doesn't strike me as that important I
mean the fraction of permutations that
it even is quite large and so a select
for the signature
makes some sense
okay
I think that's a fine wfr function
yeah I think both of these last two are
a little more tenuous but they were
related number is
probably trying to be separate from an
island number
this doesn't seem necessary this seems
like a find a real far function again
okay
all right good stuff
nothing else
okay and that's all for today thanks to
people on live stream see you all soon
bye thanks everyone bye